alors à quoi ça peut bien servir après
midi pédagogique et ludique au jardin
eugène fleuret création d'un refuge pour
insectes atelier potager ou encore
massif floral de nombreuses animations
étaient proposées pour les enfants ce
mercredi ensoleillé des enfants et
quelques adultes curieux également pour
avoir des petits conseils et des petites
astuces pour le
mon petit bout de jardin que j'ai à la
maison on avait vu qu'il y avait la
semaine
oui mais pas mal de choses à avoir ça
donc on s'est dit tiens on va les voir
les jardiniers on le voit souvent dans
la ville donc voilà pour avoir des
conseils pour la maison inscrit dans le
cadre de la semaine du développement
durable ces ateliers sont également
l'occasion pour les agents de la ville
de partager leurs connaissances et leur
savoir faire
les gens nous voient nous demande
beaucoup de conseils constamment très
souvent nous sollicite donc là ça permet
de répondre de temps en temps aux
attentes de chacun où on essaie de
transmettre
et puis effectivement de partager quoi
c'est le but de l'opération également à
transmettre et partager c'est aussi
l'idée de l'opération quand même
dimanche marquera la fin de la semaine
du développement durable à voisins le
bretonneux
d'ici là d'autres animations vous
permettront de récolter des informations
précieuses avant de vous mettre à
jardiner